Hello everyone, welcome to the DDPS
seminar. Uh before we introduce our
invited speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. Uh first of all,
please please mute yourself during the
talk.
But if you have questions, you can
unmute and ask questions or use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in Q&A session at the
end. Second, today's DDPS seminar is
open to external audience. Therefore, no
classified discussion is allowed. So,
please watch out. Finally, the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel. That's about it.
Now, let me briefly introduce our
speaker today. It is an honor to host
Alessandro Allah, who is an associate
professor at Sapienza University of Rome
since 2024. He earned a PhD in applied
mathematics from Sapienza in 2014.
Before joining Sapienza, he held
positions as an assistant professor at
Kafos Kari University of Venice. an
adjunct professor at PUC Rio Brazil and
a post-doctoral fellow at the Florida
State University and the University of
Hamburg in Germany. His research focuses
on optimal control for PDEs, motor order
reduction and datadriven modeling. Today
Alice uh Alessandro uh will talk about
datadriven algorithms for online
identification and control of partial
differential equations. I'm sure we are
going to hear a wonderful talk. Now let
me ask a a somewhat informal questions
to Aleandro just to get to know him
better and make this seminar somewhat
informal. Is that okay Aleandro? Yeah.
Okay. Here you go. Um so do you have any
superpower uh like unusual habit or
unusual the routines you do um which is
distinguishing from others uh and helps
you you know you know what you know so I
was I was expecting something I mean
usually people ask me something like
that I say I do math but here I mean
it's not Well, that's Yeah, that could
that could be a superpower. I mean,
why why do you think that's the
superpower? Uh, Matt, no, I don't know.
I'm just I'm just kidding. No, I I do
not have a superpower. I'm sorry. How
about the interesting
How about the interesting habit you
have? I like I like traveling. I like
traveling. Traveling. I mean, you are in
Italy. Uh, so that's perfect answer. Any
favorite place to go? Well, um I spent
four years in Brazil. So, Rio de Janeiro
to me is one of the best place in the
world to Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
I never Brazil. So, um you absolutely
have to go want to go. I mean, Rio de
Janeiro, it's summer all year around.
You go to the beach, you you can hike,
you go to the beach, you can party, you
can do I mean many things. Absolutely
amazing. Okay. Uh, my bucket list, but I
suggest you to go if you speak Port when
you speak Portuguese. So, there's a
process. You learn Portuguese and then
you go to Re Janeiro. Oh, I see. Okay.
All right. There you go. Stage is yours.
Okay. Thank you very much for this
opportunity. Thank you all for for being
here. Um, wherever you are. So, here
it's 700 p.m. So, I can say good
afternoon, good morning, and good night.
Um
anyway, so this this talk um is a is a
joint work with Julia Bertalis
and Anaco
and it's about um optimal control when
the the dynamics is not completely
known. So that's why you see also
identification. So I'm trying to combine
things uh on datadriven modeling but
applied to control. Uh so before I get
uh into the topic I just want to
advertise couple of events that we are
um we are organizing in Rome that you
are very welcome to to come and and
join. So registration is free. So you
just have to register. So we will have a
some both are in September. the two
consecutive weeks. So if you want to
come to to Rome and spend two weeks, you
have a uh an opportunity or if you like
an excuse. Um
so one is about a school on scientific
machine learning also PhD and postoc are
very welcome to to present uh short talk
or posters depends on the amount of uh
uh people that want to do that. And then
the week after we have a workshop on
optimal control and agent system.
So just feel free to to contact me and
also feel free to stop me anytime during
the talk. I'm very happy to receive
question to be stopped during the talk.
So this is the outline of my talk.
Basically I'm going to split the talks
in two parts. The topic is the same but
two different approaches. one is about
uh for those of you familiar with the
Cindi the sparse identification or
linear dynamical system the first part
and um and also it's a it also addresses
some reinforcement learning ideas and
the second part is about the use of
physics informed neural network in this
context of identification and and
control. So let's start with the first
one with the first part. Um those are
the two main references for this part of
the talk. Those are the two papers uh
where you find all the details that I'm
going to skip during this uh this part.
So let me first set the my control
problem. So you see here we have a uh
a dynamics which is given by nonlinear
dynamics. So this a is a function of of
the state x. So x for me in this part is
the state u is the control and also b um
depends on the dynamics
and then we have a quadratic cost
function that we want to minimize. So
maybe some of you that are familiar with
the linear quad regulator. So in general
you have x dot= ax + b u. In this case,
this is a generalization where you see
that A and B also depends on the state.
So here I I have all the classical
assumption to guarantee asinto
stabilization on the matrix A Q R and so
on. So to solve this problem as I
mentioned if you have a linear quadratic
setting usually the control you can get
the control or let's say the value
function solving the algebraic C
equation which is given here. This is a
nonlinear matrix equation and um and
then the control has this structure
where you see that you have r and r from
the cost functional b from the dynamics
and then pi from the solution the
algebraic equation. So in this situation
where there are no constraints on the
control you can exactly solve and this
there are many different works on
approximation the algebraic equation
also for a large scale problem. So you
can use kr subspace you can use newton
methods but uh nowadays there are very
valid routine to solve this to
approximate this problem very high
dimensional problem then if you want to
switch to nonlinear problem and setting
uh with a similar setting to this you
see that now I have I put in red the the
dependence on the of the problem on the
state a of x and b of x but if you
freeze at each iteration at each time
your current position. You see that you
have to solve you can solve that using a
state dependent C equation. So at the
position X you have to solve you can
solve you can get the control for this
nonlinear problem uh solving the state
dependent equation. You see that you
have the exactly the same structure but
that depends on X. So at each iteration
at each time at each position you have
to update your the solution of the
algebraic equation and then you can
solve you can get the the the control
that in this case it's just suboptimal
because the because it's not guaranteed
that your value function has this
quadratic struct structure just locally
and here you see that you have uh you
can get the control you see here the
differences are just that d and pi that
depends on the state on the current
state. So you can think about the state
dependent equation as a model predictive
control with instantaneous control. So
you freeze and you solve an RQR problem.
Nevertheless, you can you can't prove
that this is optimal. This is just
suboptimal because what you are doing
you are assuming that your value
function can be locally uh quadratic. So
this is a an approximation of the value
function.
And then from a computational point of
view as I mentioned you have to solve an
algebraic equation at each time in
iteration. So this is very dem demanding
it's very I mean my my point of view is
to solve large scale problem. So for
instance PDEs so that means that if you
discretize a PD two dimensional PD you
easily end up with a with um a large
system of differential equation in
dimension 10 to the four or even even
larger. So that means for an algebraic
card equation you have 10 to the 8
unknown. So that's very very expensive.
So here just to uh to refer to a recent
work with Dante and Valerini where we
address the problem of using state
dependent equation for right dimensional
problem and in H2 and H infinity
control.
Okay let me get into the topic of
inification and control. So as you can
imagine my um my control will be
computed using the state dependent
recarding approach. So now let me let me
think also that my dynamics is not
completely unknown. You see here that
I'm supposeding to to I'm assuming to
have a linear combination for my
dynamics. So aj those are a bunch of
matrices that uh that will build my
library and then I have some coefficient
here that uh that are unknown. So I have
a library and I have some conficient I
want to discover these coefficient
coefficients plus I want to compute my
control. So I have two unknowns the
control and the coefficient. So I want
to identify the dynamics but that I that
that I want to control.
Um so this is a a classical datadriven
uh approximation like in this in a syn
structure basically. Um
so a let me stress that a j are known
for all j's and also b is known.
What are our assumptions? So this is a
almost a reinforcement learning
assumption. So we do not know the system
but we can observe the system namely
that if you give me an input u of t and
an initial condition I can compute I can
observe the the trajectory. So this mu
star means that I can I can exactly
observe the the problem. So I do not
know my mu coefficients but if you give
me u of t I can observe the dynamics
through the trajectory. Okay. So the
goal is as I mentioned the control of of
unknown problem. I want to discover on
the fly the problem. So I want to
identify on the fly and I want to have
also efficient and accurate
approximation. So this is a
reinforcement learning assumption. But
here in this case we are not we want to
do everything on the fly. So we do not
want to observe many times the
trajectory.
During the talk I will use mu as a
generic parameter, mu star as the true
configuration and mutilda my estimate
configuration.
And then whenever I use this coefficient
I want to stress which control for
instance this control means this is the
control which is associated to my
estimate parameter. the dynamics here.
This is the dynamics that I can observe
this dynamics given this control which
is computed through my estimate and
plugged into the system that I do not
know. And if I want to stress that I'm
using
um
an approximate method, I will put he the
i here to say that I'm computing at the
time ti. So this is the discrete
approximation.
So again this is the cost function. I
keep the quadratic structure for my cost
function. So this is um as in the RQR
problem and the workflow is to pick a
parameter configuration. So an initial
guess I compute the corresponding
control given this initial guess for the
parameter. I observe the trajectory.
Then I update the parameter cons conf
configuration based on the observation
and I keep iterating this. A certain
point I will stop to update my parameter
configuration when I see that there is
not much difference between two
iterations.
So now I I I need to tell you how to
compute mu which is very important.
So as I mentioned I start with an
initial configuration. I can compute my
control.
After I compute my control, I get the
trajectory. Okay, a discrete trajectory.
When I compute the discrete trajectory,
I can plug into the system. Remember
that I have an answer for my for my
trajectory. I have here a linear
combination. Okay, but I can compute the
aj into the trajectory and also the
control. This is feedback control. So I
know the structure of the control. So
this turns out to be a linear regression
problem basically. So you see on the
left I have this this vector the
derivative and the the control
contribution and then the my library
times my my vector. So this is a linear
regression problem and we do compute the
linear we do solve the linear regression
problem using basian linear regression.
Uh this is mainly I mean you can use any
whatever you prefer. You can also use
optimization or loss optimization, ridge
optimization, whatever whatever you
prefer. Here for some reason based on
reinforcement learning, we we use the
basal linear regression but the results
will not be much different if you use
another uh another um another method and
then again we learn the system on the
fly. So the algorithm works as follow as
I mentioned. So I get an initial
configuration. I solve my algebraic
equation. I compute the feedback control
and after that I get the feedback
control. I can observe the trajectory
and then I get my update for the
parameter using the uh basian linear
regression. I actually we actually put a
stop area here to update the parameter
configuration. When two uh parameter
estimates are very close to each other,
we stop the algorithm.
Let me give you some test. So in one of
the paper we also worked using model
reduction for this but here we not f
focus on on that. So we just uh we are
just working on one-dimensional um we
are just working on one-dimensional PTE
but you see here that we have many PDs
here you can think having petition
adection diffusion you can think having
Alen Khan Zovich
uh KDV burgers so you have many
combinations so you see I have just
seven parameters to discover but I have
many different
uh problem and from a control point of
view each of them are different uh
features. So if you have a a parabolic
problem is different from an epolic
problem. So that makes also the control
problem not that easy. Although we have
just seven coefficients and sometimes we
use
zero dish boundary condition or normal
boundary condition that depends on the
problem. But you see here that if you
discretize this kind this problem you
get into the state dependent approach.
My matrix A of X is the discret this is
the discretization of the second order
derivative. This is the discretization
of the adection term. Then we have the
polomial structure and then we have the
matrix for the third order derivative or
the or here we have the the burkas
ninarity. In order to approximate this
problem we we use the Jacobian free
Newton kilome method which turns out to
be very efficient for high dimensional
high dimensional problem.
So let me start with the viscous ber. So
this is the problem that we want to
identify. So this is the uh what we get
from our observation. This is the
problem behind our observation. And you
see that we have a low diffusion and we
have a burgers a burger stems. So those
are some parameter where we control and
the dimension of the discrete problem
and you see here that using our method.
So this is the true configuration. This
is the reconstructive here. So this is
the diffusion part. Um this is the
burgers nonlinearity and all the the
other coefficients are almost zero close
to zero. I mean this also uh depends on
the discretization here. So the the
difference here is below our delta t. So
that makes um consistent with what we
were expecting. And here you see the the
solution of the uncontrol problem. So
uncontrol problem means that u is equal
zero
and then here we have the you have the
solution the control solution. So using
state dependent recog straightforward
for the known problem and here where we
do identification and control you see
that they are pretty similar but a more
precise um stud is given here for
instance here you see the two different
control the control U1 and U2 are the
control that comes from the state
dependent calcation so when the dynamics
is no and when you see RL so this is our
approach you see that they're pretty
similar Here there is a difference but
that was our choice to start with U
equals Z at the beginning you are free I
mean basically you're free and you can
get even better better result here you
see the convergence of the parameter
configuration at the as at the beginning
it's very uh changing a lot but then
it's converging to a certain a certain
configuration and here the valuation of
the cost functional as expected the cost
functional for the state dependent
approach is is below but uh there's not
much difference between our approach and
the state dependent remind
the dynamic is not known so we have an
error in the identification which is
also which is clearly reflected here
from a CPU time point of view uh of
course uncontrol problem is rather cheap
but there is no control involved and
here you see that uh it's rather similar
it's rather similar that because the the
amount of uh recation that you have to
solve which is the most expensive part
in the in this problem. So you see this
is just the simulation without control.
So this is the most expensive part the
the the solution the approximation the
equation and you have just one about one
second more more expensive here just a
linear regression problem more than
here.
Um
so I tried to to give an idea about uh
identification and control with for
unknown PDS using some reinforcement
learning assumption where you do not
know the model but you can observe and
on the the difference is that
um we do that on the fly. So we do not
get the many observations basically. uh
I show you numerical convergence of for
our for our experiments and in this talk
I did not address but we also work on
using model reduction for higher
dimensional problems was someone was
wanted to ask me something yeah um since
you you're you're finishing the first
part the first part yeah yeah okay cool
so I guess it's a good time to close and
then ask questions Um um so previous
examples um how many state variable did
you have like it was 121 I mean this is
a onedimensional PTE so you don't get
the large scale oh but that's the
discretized version yes the discretized
after discretization you got the 121 but
since it's 1D you have a onear you do
not get yeah then then in the in a
second word that I'm not going to
present here because I want to watch and
switch and use the physics inform
approach. Uh we also have something
which is 10 to the four the dimension.
Okay, got it. And then and then we
combined with model reduction in order
to to approximate I mean to to get
something efficient and accurate. Okay.
And then optimal control um
demonstration you showed um you are
assuming this equation is not known and
then you um
by regressions you know Cindy exactly
you you identify that yeah yeah it's
basically the apply to control problem
so in that scenario what if the I mean
in the regression you have to provide a
set of library you know candid library
and what if you know some of the
essential uh term is not provided. Yeah.
Mhm. Well, so what we did here um
we didn't address that. Um but but but
for us I mean I I try to have a more
control point of view in a sense that uh
here um we have a several problem to
control basically and if you think about
a control problem it it's I mean then if
you add more terms that means that maybe
your problem is not controllable okay so
I also wanted to make sure that I could
compute my control
Right. Otherwise, I I I got I got other
issues. And then also from a control
point of view here, since you have many
different combinations and many
different interesting control problems
that I I thought that was that was
enough to to to address this. But yeah,
I agree. I but I agree. I think in
general I mean if you have libraries I
mean more libraries or not exact
libraries that this approach might not
work. I mean I absolutely agree if that
was your point.
Yeah. Like I mean underlying assumption
you have is you know those you know
chosen libraries by user um hopefully
that includes the true system equation.
Yeah. Yeah. No, for for us for us
absolutely we we had the true I mean for
us we knew exactly it's it's not p
purely datadriven in a sense that we
knew the structure of the problem but we
didn't I mean only the m coefficient
were unknown okay but for a control
point of view I mean I guess it's not
that uh easy to to find libraries out of
the blue without knowing information
because you end up that the recigation
is not solvable, right? Yeah. So then
what do you do?
Yeah, that's tough problem. Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly. I mean that that's u that's my
that's my point of view and that's
that's the reason why um we we got
exactly the same library basically.
Okay. Cool. Is there any other question
from audience? Because we just finished
the first part and
Alessandro will move on to the second
part. Before that, if you have question
Okay, maybe maybe at the end. Maybe at
the end. Okay, cool. Let's see. Uh so
now same problem but different approach.
Physics informal network. I still have
uh about 20 minutes, right? More or
less.
Yeah, more or less. Yeah. Okay. So I
guess you are
all familiar with physics informal
network but so before starting let me
just mention that uh so when we started
to investigate here you see in red the
our contribution
we found uh
not not many works on control using
physics inform here I'm listing some of
them perhaps this list is not complete
but um I feel that this is still a very
open uh open topic. I mean if you if you
think that the physics in 4 were
introduced maybe five six years ago I
mean it I think it's normal that optimal
control with this approach is still very
very open. So what is physics informed
network? physics inform network is a
it's a way to use uh uh to to
approximate differential equation using
neuron network providing physics
information and the physics information
means that we in the loss function we
provide we want to minimize the residual
of the of the PD that we want to solve
here we want to use the physics in form
to solve time dependent optimal control
problem in a scenario a particular
scenario where we cannot use numerical
uh numerical methods. So say that we do
not know for instance the boundary
conditions initial or final conditions
um or just uh we just have a few data
but we do not know the structure the
continuous structure of the problem for
instance and um also in situation where
this the state integration probably are
not completely known. So in this
situation where when you do not know
boundary condition or the initial
conditions or the state equation or the
joint equation you cannot use standard
numerical methods. So this is the
situation where we are that we are
addressing um and of course that also
gets into identification because we
assume that the problem is not
completely known and control because we
want to uh to get an optimal control.
So what uh in general we will have uh
I'm slightly changing the notation. So
here we have a state which depends on
position and time. We will use a feed
forward narrow network with L + one
layers and L minus one hidden layers. Um
we will have some data some observation
and then the surrogate the narrow
network will will
return in this way. I will stress the n
here and this parameter t that will be
the object of our minimization. In fact
we will have to define different loss
functions. So for us loss function for
the data. So if we have observation for
the residual here and from the boundary
if we have data from the boundary. Okay.
So the three loss function that we're
using are data residual of the PTE and
boundary condition. So in that case you
will get uh theta for the for the
surrogate model and just to stress that
if you do not have the residual and the
boundary condition this is a standard
deep neuron network.
So we will use uh the optimization
routine is a classical atom optimizer
and um here I want to stress that f for
us which is the residual here is not
completely so we want to identify that
for the state for for optimal control
here I'm not using in feedback approach
or the state dependent approach I'm
using the standard open loop and in open
loop okay you have a parameter that you
want to control here. This is the state
equation. Um,
and I want to stress that this parameter
is not known. So this is the parameter
that we want to we want to identify. N
will be known but C here will not be
known. And then we have an optimal
control here. This is a standard
tracking problem. Quad also a quadratic
cost function where we want to get as
close as possible to a reference which
is called Y bar.
So this is a standard time dependent uh
problem uh time dependent optimal
control problem. And if you want to get
your control you can use a lrange lranch
function where you identify the the cost
a joint and the control problem and you
have the optimality condition which are
usually given the state a joint equation
which is a backward linear problem. T is
the unknown that comes here and then the
optimality condition that uh put
correlate the control and the and the
and the joint.
So our physics uh I mean our neuronet
network architecture works as follows.
So we assume to have data for the
uncontrol program to make it more
realistic because usually you do not
have data from the control program. So
what do we do from this uncontrol from
data from the uncontrol problem we try
to identify the problem. So in the first
oops in the first
network architecture we identify the
problem based on the uncontrol
structure. So you see here our f now
that does not depends on you. So in the
first at the first stage we try to
identify c. Once we identified C, we set
a second uh narrow network architecture.
You see here the live the the output is
just the uncontrol and then when after
identification we switch to a control
problem and our output will be state
control and adjint and and that's it. So
we have two different architecture
because we have to identify and usually
you do not get the data from the control
problem and then you solve the optimal
control problem. What we minimize are
exactly the same that depends on the
data. So here in the second architecture
we use some information. So we
initialize our network from uh using
this configuration for instance that
even though it it comes from the
uncontrol problem
you get some feature of the of the
dynamics.
Um
and also the loss function here that we
want to also the data will be different.
Basically here we do not use data
um and here the residual is from the
uncontrol problem.
So in our simulations we will always
have want to track our problem to to
zero.
Then uh if I want to indicate the
numerical methods or when I assume to
know the dynamics and so on, I will call
y of u star to stress that this comes
from the numerical method. Whenever the
solution comes from the physics informal
network approach, I will call y pin and
up. And if I want to plug my pin control
into my dynamics to set to check how
consistent is our result, I will call y
of pin. So y up pin is the numerical
method
using the control that comes from the
narrow network.
I want to compute a different kind of
control. So the the diff the the error
between the optimal solution the pin
solution
between the optimal control and the and
the pin control and then also the
difference between uh uh the optimal
solution and the the the solution using
the pin control. So the with the
numerical method
we will use five layers three hidden
layers with 64 no 64 nodes and the
learning rate for the Adam optimizer is
10 to the minus 3 in order to
uh to weight more our data so our
information we put 10 in front of the
data in the boundary whenever I provided
and just one in front of the rece
So first example again this is the
control the viscous burgers
that's drinking sorry so the unknown is
is this parameter the diffusion part
this is the initial condition and this
is the boundary condition so this is
unknown and also the control
this is the quadic cost function and
therefore completance I provide you the
the joint equation optimality
conditions.
So now we focus on two different
scenarios. One when the diffusion 0.5 so
which is um more parabolic problem and
one when the diffusion is 0.05 so that
the vection is dominating. We're just
using 10 data.
No initial condition is provided and the
boundary condition is just a sparse
level. We just have 18 points to check
the boundary condition
where we test our narrow network. We
have 336
points and our um threshold to stop our
meth is 10 to the minus 7.
So now the problem is very is diffusive.
So in black sorry in white you see the
point the data that we are considering
from the uncontrol problem you see that
the initial condition is not considered
and in black
you should see probably so here
here here those points are the boundary
condition that I'm data about the
boundary condition so I'm not providing
the boundary condition I'm just
providing some sparse data
and GR. So this is from the uncontrol
problem and this is what you expect from
the control problem. You see that
um the data from the boundary are the
same and this is the initial condition.
This is something that you can discover
from the uh the network using the
uncontrolled setting.
So this is the optimal solution. The
solution that we expect from using
numerical method when everything is
known. This is the uncontrolled
solution. So you see that it is going to
zero faster. Get it's getting flat uh
flat faster. And this is the pin
solution. I mean from a visual point of
view you see here that they are pretty
similar.
This is the the optimal control and the
pin control. Again it's difficult to see
um to visualize the difference. So here
in zero this is not exactly zero but
nevertheless they they have a very good
agreement. So let me let let's try to
quantify the error. So all the errors so
difference between the control the
optimal control and the pin control
state optimal state and the pin solution
is always about between 10 to the minus
2 and 10 to theus 3. This is the our
level of accuracy and you see here a
comparison of the final time. So this is
the uncontrol solution and this is the
three different strategies and the at
the final time the state at the final
time. You see that there is an error
clearly but uh the narrow network it's
getting what he has it has to do and
this is how the uh the diffusion is
converging towards the the ground truth.
So this is the
um the side configuration and this is
how we are converging to the to the
ground.
Let's go to something which is uh more
uh adection dominating. Same structure
few data but you see now how important
is the vection here and also is also
clear more clearly how the control is
working. So you see that this is going
to zero faster than this. In fact here
you have the uncontrolled solution. This
is the uncontrol the control solution.
And again they are very similar.
This was interesting for us because this
I mean usually from control problem if
you have a an adection dominated problem
this is harder but nevertheless even
keeping the same order accuracy which is
always something between 10 to the minus
2 10 to the minus 3
you can get uh you can make the pin
approach working. So this is the a
comparison between the the controls
and al again This is the conversions of
the diff to the diffusion parameter and
the solution the final time. You see
here the error behavior but the results
are very similar to the previous the
previous case.
Let's go to alen camp.
So now we have a a polomial nonlinearity
y to the three. So this this control
problem is rather interesting because
the the uncontrol problem is going I
mean this problem the uncontrol problem
has three equilibrium and the uncontrol
problem goes to the stable equilibrium
which is + one or minus one depending on
the initial condition.
Uh so if you want to get uh to the
solution to zero you have to apply you
can apply control and again the
diffusion is the unknown part.
Again quadratic cost functional we want
to track zero this is the join and this
is the optimality conditions
and we are using two different scenario
the diffusion 0.1
and we have mu= 1. So this is an easy
case and then second case is the
diffusion is one but the ninarity is 11.
So this is uh the interesting part from
a control point of view and also we we
were working with two different kind of
initial condition condition one which
was just positive and the second one
which also was changing the sign and
again we work with a few amount of data
just 12 data for for the uncontrol
solution and 14 data for the b uh um no
12 12 points for the boundary conditions
get we we do not use any data from
control and a joint. So all the
information that we have comes from the
uncontrolled solution
uh 520 points for receiver and the stop
that is 10 to the minus 5 you see in
white the amount of data that we're
using and in black on the on the
boundary. So same idea 0.1 diffusion and
one for the non 10. You see how
the uncontrol problem is gets to the
sort of steady state here and the
control solution is going to zero. Those
are very similar again
the control we have an agreement
and this is how looks like how it looks
like the the solution on the final time.
It's it's clear the difference between
uncontrol problem and control problem.
And here we have the conversion towards
the the ground truth the error what we
found that was always something between
-2 and -3.
So this was more so here the unc control
gets um so the the the maximum the
initial condition is 0.2 and you always
get 0.2 two
if you change this this coefficient in
front of the linear term I mean here
it's always similar the amount of data
that we are using
so this is increasing now the problem is
is less stable is increasing and you see
the the control solution that is going
to zero
and also the initial condition now
changing the sign which makes the
problem a a little bit more difficult.
This is the control is very active at
the beginning then it gets to zero and
again the convergence of the to the
desired configuration and the solution
the final time error is always between
10 to theus 2 minus three.
So coming from control and numerical
analysis,
we were trying to understand when to use
and why to use physics informal network
because from um from accuracy point of
view and the efficiency point of view
I mean accuracy
I I understood that um something order
minus three it's usually accepted. So
you you can never beat a numerical
method efficiency
there are numerical method that very are
very efficient nowadays also for
dimensional problem so the use of neuron
network does not make the very efficient
I mean straightforward
this approach so we were thinking when
to use that so situation where you know
you do not you do not know the problem
you are just a few information then this
form neuronet network in my opinion is
very is very interesting and is very
useful otherwise you cannot do anything.
Um
so this uh in the paper we we were we we
wrote a very long conclusion where we
were addressing all these question
that's is something that I'm something
during the talk I I somehow address and
we were I mean that was our
interpretation. So this uh drives me to
the conclusion. So in this second part I
was I presenting something about
extension of physics informal network to
control problem where the control
problem is not completely known the
dynamics is not completely known. So we
were using this approach to identify and
comput and compute control. So with that
I really would like to thank you for
your attention for being here till the
end. Thank you. Thank you so much for
the nice talk Alessandro
and um I loved it um and especially this
slides you you know some comments and
the conclusions about the pins and
giving us a some foodful thoughts and I
guess it's a trap for the the questions
from audience they can use this one yeah
I'm I mean also if you are not familiar
with control and you want to share your
experience so Maybe I was I mean I I'm I
do not come from an error network and uh
but I mean my experience was always this
kind of error. So if you have a better
experience of suggestions I'm very happy
to hear your opinion which uh which
captures more you know similar
experience I had with the pins as well.
um as you said um you know numerical
traditional numerical methods in terms
of accuracy and speed probably it
outperforms the pins and that's what I
have seen it before uh yeah yeah but if
you don't don't have anything any data
uh maybe pins is the only options you
can yeah yeah yeah you can use so
honestly honestly I started to do a very
simple uh problem linear integration
um using pins with it equation no
control and oh I was getting 10 to the
main stream nothing better
yeah yeah there's a convergence issue
with with the pins
and and I was not able to get any
convergence like you know I mean I was
expecting to have I mean I don't know
maybe I have more layers more nodes more
data something I mean I was not able to
get some order convergence out of that
which made me I mean well maybe I made
mistake I don't know but uh no no no
it's like this is this is the thread an
exactly common trend I mean yeah that's
that too like a lot of trial and errors
you have to go through you know yeah
exactly
it's it's it's humongous
um okay uh Boris yes please everyone
hiandro thanks for the nice talk hi
Boris I had a question on your um the
first part where you showed uh I didn't
ask it at that point but where you
showed uh convergence of the control
signal and then convergence of the um
energy or in the first part. Yeah. In
the first part. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. So um somehow the
the the difference in the control
doesn't seem to be or or how am I
interpreting the differences in the
control coming from RL
um and the U1's and U2s that you have
computed
um they don't seem to show up in the
cost function is it so what's your
weight on control that was my question I
think
um so the
it reflects in a sense that uh this is
more exp I mean is a little bit higher
than this one. So
but what what you see here is just uh at
the bit it's just at the first iteration
this is our choice to put u equals zero
okay but then at the second the second
step I mean they are pretty much
matching you see so it's just the first
at the first iteration that there is
this difference and then uh and then if
you think about the cost you paid zero
at the beginning at the first at the
first iteration right by because of the
choice Right.
So that that is maybe the reason also
that is not expensive but okay now I
see. Yeah. Yeah. Now now I see that in
the paper in the paper I think um we
also addressed that and we did uh in one
of the two I think in the second paper
the one with using model reduction we
did not do starting from zero. Okay. So
you you do not even see this this
discrepancy. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Fine.
Yeah, just wanted to clarify and see
that I understood the figure. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you. You're welcome.
Any other questions?
So, are you planning to, you know, apply
this to like a higher dimensional uh
system like 2D, 3D for using a lot? Um
well for this one for this approach
we have done uh for two dimensional PDs.
Um
not fancy PDS. So if you if you ask me
if I did for Navia Stokes or something
for fluid I haven't done that. Um for
pins
I don't know because two dimensional PDs
that means that it's very expensive from
a compositional point of view. So I
think something has to be done to make
it more efficient. Otherwise uh it's
very very costly in my opinion. Yeah.
Because I mean it's it's not just one
one PD we have three PD I mean two PDs
to solve basically use a joint and
state. So it might be very expensive in
my opinion. Yeah
that if you if you have references to
make it more efficient I'm happy to to
receive
Yeah. Um well I mean really impactful
application for the in general control
problem is robotic control. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. No no I'm just
thinking like in general uh in general
in a sense that if you have a n
dimensional problem you want to use neon
network
at least straightforward and this way I
mean it can be very expensive. Yeah I
mean the the reason I brought up the
robotic I mean I don't have experience
with it. Maybe Boris has some experience
with the the robotic control there. the
uh you know number of variables you
treat is not that high right it's not
the we are not dealing with the like
thousands or millions of degrees of
freedom which comes no no with robotic
you can I mean I think robotic you can I
mean you can get
different levels of dimensions basically
and how do you see the application of
that your first approach like using the
sparse regression in the incorporating
in the optimal control and apply apply
that to the robotic uh applications.
I I I would say I mean I do not know the
structure of the robotic um of the
robotic I mean the equation comes from
of the robotic force. So I don't know I
don't I'm not sure if you can get I mean
uh probably you can write in a in a
setting uh uh as a state dependent.
Um,
so the key point is not the control in
my opinion. The key point is the are the
libraries for this approach in general
for Cindy. So if you have information
about the libraries, I think I think
it's pretty doable.
You mean like the um
um variable library is it known? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So what I call AJ
in in this in this part
I I guess those system is not known in
general in robberics. I don't know Boris
if you can comment on that. Um so in
that case if it is not no that means so
you are thinking about something like
purely datadriven that you don't exactly
exactly so data. Yeah. But use the Cindy
um to identify some sort of you know
surrogate model. It does not have to be
exact coin. Yeah. Yeah. I mean but that
I would say that from that point of view
the key point is the libraries then
everything is is doable
in my opinion. I mean
okay
uh you have a question right? Yeah.
Hands up. Uh Alejandro. Yeah, thanks
thanks for the presentation. So I was
wondering which optimizer did you use
for the pins problems?
Uh Adam. Adam. Okay. So in our test
cases we you know we were using Adam and
then Adam plus LBFGS but then recently
we found another optimizer called soap
which is basically shampoo with Adam in
the preconditioner basis. So that giving
pretty good result and it's very
completely efficient much better. Can
you can you write the name of the
optimizer on the chat please? Yeah.
Yeah. I'll I'll I'll refer the paper.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Thank you very much.
Yeah. It's also if you have a paper
Thank you. Yeah. So I'm Yeah, I'm typing
it now.
How how efficient is it? uh pattern like
it's with you know compared to LVFGs
it's almost 10 times efficient yeah and
the good thing is that you don't need to
use Adam in conjunction with you know
shampoo or soap you just use the soap
optimizer right away
very good tip thank you so yeah I'm also
posting one paper uh from pedicures
group Wong and pedicuries. I think they
they tested it on pins problem and for
all the problems uh they found better
results. Uh okay. Yeah. Thanks for
sharing. Yeah, no problem.
Cool. Is there any other question?
If not, let's let's thank our speaker
for the nice talk. Uh, Alessandro,
it was a very nice talk and um, thank
you very much, very nice numerical
results and thank you for sharing with
us um, through this DDP seminar.
Hopefully uh, you get more network and
connections and uh, I would say future
future collaborations
that would mean wonderful. Okay. Well,
with that
byebye.
Bye bye manage.